[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed for coming to
this debate which is called thinking
straight the social drug of choice in
Western culture is alcohol yet it is
estimated to kill 100,000 people in the
year in the UK alone
the independent scientific committee on
drugs puts it near the top of the list
of dangerous drugs while others like
ecstasy LSD and cannabis come much lower
down should we wean ourselves off
alcohol or even ban it and instead
promote other less harmful but currently
illegal alternatives or do we think the
benefits of alcohol are just too great
to take this seriously now on the
platform witness on the far left is
nigel inc step is the former director of
operations and intelligence for the for
mi6 the British Secret Intelligence
Service and he's also the author of
several books including drugs insecurity
and failed States the problems of
prohibition and currently senior adviser
to the International Institute for
Strategic Studies next to me is thangam
debonair she's the Labour MP for Bristol
West she describes herself as a
Democratic Socialist and the supporter
of fettered capitalism and in 2018 she
took part in BBC documentary drugs land
most or large parts of it shot in her
constituency on my right is Michael link
C professor of addictions in the
National addiction Center Michael has
published extensively on issues related
to cannabis use and cannabis use
disorders he was principal investigator
of the Midwest and alcoholism Research
Center also I'm RIT is Richard Bentall
his professor of clinical psychology at
the University of Sheffield and his
books include madness explained and
doctoring the mind and he's best known
for his research into psychosis
hallucinations and paranoid delusions
and right off we go now why aren't we
treating the dangers of alcohol more
seriously and that assumes they were all
agreed that alcohol
is really dangerous is it Nigel
well I'm not an expert on this
particular area other than as an
enthusiastic consumer of the product but
I mean I think you know there's a range
of psychoactive substances that human
beings have a propensity to use and
abuse and it's not actually just human
beings there's a small child in Africa
I've seen elephants getting drunk on
fermented fruit so your other species
apparently feel much the same way as
ourselves and you know I take the view
that the whole question of use of
psychoactive substances is one of those
issues that you're never going to be
able to solve it's something you have to
manage and the question is how you do
managers without questions are a society
do you think society understands the
dangers before we get on to the question
of how you manage it yeah they're
suggested in this question is that
people don't quite understand how
dangerous it is yeah and politicians in
particular are rather scared of pointing
that out well I think there is that
because of course we'd arrived in this
country and other countries enormous
revenues from alcohol consumption and
you know no government would likely
forego that that kind of support but I
think in terms of education about the
risks there is probably you know there
are probably things that we could do
differently we keep on getting from the
chief medical officer different
assessments of how much alcohol is safe
and then you hear you know some medical
specialist saying well you know no
amount of alcohol is safe the only thing
to do is you know is to drink water well
yeah but I mean your life is about risk
and about manage risk and you know there
are lots of things that ideally we
should stop doing altogether but
realistically we're not going to and
alcohol
I do think has an upside so your
suggestions not that we don't understand
on the whole the dangers of alcohol your
argument will be about the way in which
we deal with that but don't think what's
broad for immediately is unmask
advertising campaign about the dangers
of alcohol well no but I think about a
mass education campaign which is more
thoughtful and sensitive and you're a
nuanced might actually be helpful in
terms of how you go about educating
people to drink safely Sangam can ask
you the same question
why aren't we treating the dangers of
alcohol more seriously didn't we're
treating alcohol seriously enough and
absolutely not and and and I also know
of the report in which the chief medical
officer said that there is no safe level
of alcohol consumption and the reason
the chief medical officer said there is
no safe level of alcohol consumption is
because there is no safe level of
alcohol consumption but there is a
managed risk approach which we take to
all sorts of risks in life and I think
there are four main reasons why we
aren't treating those risks properly one
is that we either don't know the risks
fully or we don't want to acknowledge
them and particular people often know
that alcohols that are linked with liver
disease but they may not realize that
there's a causal link with breast bowel
and other forms of cancer
indeed I didn't until I had breast
cancer at which point it became
relatively straightforward when a
surgeon said to me one of the things you
can do to reduce your risk of recurrence
of breast cancer is to stop drinking it
became relatively straightforward not to
become quite as teetotal as you asked
earlier but to become more of a noun a
royal approach to drinking so sherry
every so often in a champagne at
weddings at type of approach to alcohol
but certainly not habitual alcohol
consumption that would describe my
position and that's because I am more
aware of the dangers of alcohol but I
also think the legal status confers some
sort of illusion of safety and that
perfect poses challenges to those of us
who want reform of the law on other
drugs
I think we're socialized to treat
alcohol consumption as the norm and also
the alcohol lobby so young um Nigel
mentioned that politicians aren't very
fond of pointing out the dangers of
alcohol indeed when I did in a lovely
article here called the moment I saw the
light about alcohol and cancer and I was
immediately targeted by so-called
academics who turned out not to be quite
that academic representing the alcohol
lobby but disguising the fact they're
representing the alcohol lobby sending
me serious bits of pseudoscience
telling me actually that I got it all
wrong and alcohol was completely safe so
I think though there are four really
clear reasons I think there's also the
dangers that people don't appreciate
include not just the health dangers but
the wider social dangers the dangers the
public's face the dangers to intimate
partner violence for instance which is
the Fieldays working there's any number
of those dangers which people either
don't acknowledge or don't want to
acknowledge but I'm not saying that if
you just lectured everybody with the
dangers they'd all immediately know
right come on over Michael I mean dude
again if you think that there is a real
problem in terms of education or of
policy our people seized enough of the
problems and that we should not worry so
much about that it is the way in which
we do with those problems it should be
the focus I officially thank you for
inviting me here and I think one thing
with alcohol is it is so embedded in our
society alcohol is very much a part of
our traditions it's a part of so many
functions and everything else and I
think because of that people do minimize
problems some of it as you said it's
because there's a perception that it's
legal so it must be safe and as soon as
I turn 18 it's legal and therefore safe
for me to drink but that isn't the case
in terms of actual safety so there was a
very large global project to try to
estimate burden of disease associated
with specific risk factors and one of
the things they looked at was alcohol
consumption and countries like the UK
alcohol accounts for about somewhere
between 8 and 10 percent of all
preventable illness and mortality I'd
actually like to compare that just a
slightly hijack decision to compare that
with risks associated with cannabis use
which in that same project account for
0.2% so 140th or 150th of the health
harms associated with alcohol but we
have a far different approach to
cannabis than we have for alcohol
and that it intrigues me it is changing
a lot in America at the moment where
there is the emergence of a cannabis
industry which may include such things
as advertising quite aggressive
marketing and so forth in terms of you
know which so used to things and
surrounding alcohol including you know
the number of booths which fortunately
are available and are we visiting at
least one of them later okay at the
session but why do we treat cannabis
differently from alcohol I mean I will
want to pick up that's point but I just
asked you here to do we need drugs in
the sense that is there a basic human
need for drugs in that it is a way of us
coping with life it is a way of maybe
relaxing which we will need to do
periodically because there would be
mental health problems if we didn't
relax so is the question that you always
have to balance as it were physical
dangers physical health dangers and some
mental health dangers associated with
drugs with beneficial elements of drug
use that may actually help human beings
as a whole and so that's so do we need
to keep that in mind
I mean I think we do there are positive
aspects of any drug use including
alcohol or cannabis I don't think we
need those drugs so to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit a I dot TV for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas